So we know forests play an essential role
in regulating the Earth's climate.
However, most of what we know
about those forests
is actually based on things
we can measure aboveground.
So historically, ecologists like myself
would come to this place,
and we’d count the number
of tree stems we’d find.
We’d identify which species they are,
and today we’d probably remotely sense
features of this forest canopy from space.
And all of this absolutely makes sense.
Aboveground is where
photosynthesis happens.
Photosynthesis is how carbon
and energy enter forests.
Photosynthesis is how trees
can remove carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere.
However, we also know most trees
are limited in some way,
by soil resources like water or nutrients.
And to access those resources,
trees have to build roots.
And trees build
an incredible amount of roots.
So in some forests, there can be
as much or more biomass belowground,
in root structures,
as aboveground, in stems and leaves.
Decades of research
have now made very clear
that belowground ecology --
so what’s going on in the soil --
is really essential to understanding
how these forest systems work.
However, if you follow these root systems
all the way out to their terminal ends,
the finest tips in the root system,
and you look closely --
I mean super closely,
like, you’re going to need
a microscope closely --
you discover a place
where the tree stops being a plant,
and starts becoming a fungus.
So most trees on Earth form a partnership,
or what scientists call symbiosis,
with mycorrhizal fungi.
So this, in my opinion,
is one of the most remarkable images
ever captured of these organisms.
So in the background, at the top,
you can see this dense network
of fungal hyphae.
These are essentially like roots,
but for fungi, instead of plants.
And in the foreground,
you can see these incredible,
multinucleated fungal spores,
which look totally unreal,
but absolutely are.
These are the reproductive
structures of the fungus.
These have the potential to become
entirely new fungal networks.
Mycorrhizal fungi are essential
to how basically all plants
access limiting soil resources.
There's actually evidence
that when plants first made
the evolutionary transition
from living in water to living on land,
they evolved this symbiosis
before they even evolved roots.
And so this partnership between forests
and their fungi is ancient,
and it stretches back
hundreds of millions of years.
However, these roots
don't have to be just fungi.
They can also be, for instance, bacteria.
So these circular structures
in this root network
are called root nodules.
They house symbiotic,
nitrogen-fixing bacteria.
And what these bacteria do
is actually convert nitrogen gas
in the atmosphere
into plant-usable forms,
and in turn, they nurture plant growth.
And the complexity of soil biology
just keeps going.
So these root symbionts are embedded
in an even more complex network
of free-living bacterial
and fungal decomposers,
and archaea and protists,
microscopic soil animals, viruses ...
The biodiversity of soil
communities is astonishing.
We now know a handful of soil
can easily contain over 1,000
coexisting microbial species.
And so all of this,
this is the soil microbiome.
This is the forest microbiome,
this is the ecosystem microbiome.
So breakthroughs
in DNA sequencing technology
have finally turned
the lights on belowground.
DNA has allowed us to see
these microbial communities
in unprecedented detail,
and, only recently,
at unprecedented scales.
Yet despite these breakthroughs,
I'd argue we still don't know the answers
to seemingly simple questions, like this:
"What does a healthy
forest microbiome look like?"
We're far closer to answering
a question like this for people
than we are for plants.
The Human Microbiome Project
has really led in this area.
So the human body
is a microbial ecosystem.
Each of us houses an incredibly biodiverse
community of bacteria in our gut,
and that has a profound
impact on our health.
This was discovered
by medical microbiologists
using DNA sequencing
to characterize which bacteria
live in hundreds of people's bodies.
And importantly, also noting
health features of those same people.
So, are they sick? And if so, with what?
What's their blood pressure,
their digestive health,
their mental health?
And by combining all of that information,
those microbiologists
could begin to identify
combinations of bacteria
linked to health and disease.
And these analyses became a road map
for the development of human
microbiome transplant therapies,
which is essentially
ecosystem restoration,
but for your gut microbiome.
And these therapies
are now on the road to market
to treat some of these diseases today.
And so drawing from this work,
my team asked,
"What would it look like
to take the Human
Microbiome Project approach,
but apply it to the forest?”
What could we discover
about the forest carbon cycle?
Could we identify places
where we could actually do
belowground microbial restoration,
and, in the process,
combat climate change?
Over the past three years,
we’ve been working
with forest scientists across Europe
to do exactly that.
In each of these locations,
scientists have been documenting
forest health for decades.
And so, we asked
our forest research partners
to go out to each of these forests
and collect a small sample of soil,
which they then shipped back
to our lab in Zurich
so we could extract and sequence DNA,
which allowed us to understand
which microorganisms,
and particularly fungi,
live in each of these forests.
And then finally, we used statistics
and machine learning
to relate which microorganisms
live in a forest
to a really important
forest health metric:
tree growth rate
and carbon-capture rate aboveground.
Now, once we controlled for the
environmental drivers of tree growth --
so how warm and wet
each of these places is,
as well as other variables we know
control background site fertility --
we discovered that particularly
which fungi colonize
the roots of these trees
is linked to threefold variation
in how fast these trees grow,
how fast they remove carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere.
So put another way,
these correlations imply
that you could have two pine forests,
sitting side by side,
experiencing the same climate,
growing in the same soils.
But if one of them was colonized
by the right community
of fungi on its roots,
it could be growing up to three times
as fast as that adjacent forest.
And furthermore,
these patterns were not driven
by the presence of particularly
high-performing species or strains,
but instead, they were driven
by biodiverse and completely different
communities of fungi.
And so these fungal signatures
are super exciting to us
because they imply
an opportunity to manage,
and in many cases, actually rewild
the forest fungal microbiome.
So, for example, can we
reintroduce fungal biodiversity
into a managed timber forestry landscape?
And in the process,
can we make those trees grow faster?
Can we make them capture more carbon
in their tree stems and in their soils?
Can we rewild the soil
and combat climate change?
And these aren't
just rhetorical questions --
we've actually started doing this.
So this is one of our field trials
in Wales, in the United Kingdom.
It’s run in collaboration
with the charity there
called the Carbon Community.
It’s 28 acres, or 11 hectares,
and it's set up as
a block-randomized controlled trial.
This is analogous
to how you would run a drug trial,
but in this case,
it's for trees instead of people.
And here, we do a pretty
straightforward experiment.
We either plant trees,
business as usual --
which is just direct planting
of seedlings into the ground --
or we plant trees,
and at the moment of planting,
we add a small handful of soil.
But it's not just any soil.
It's soil sourced from a forest
our analyses have identified as harboring
potentially high-performing fungi.
So since we reintroduced
microbial biodiversity
into some of these sites,
we've observed that where
we actually did that,
we've been able to accelerate tree growth
and carbon capture in tree stems
by 30 to 70 percent,
depending on the tree species.
Or put another way --
where we manipulated and rewilded
the invisible microbiology of this place,
we’ve begun to change
how that entire place works.
Now it's important to emphasize
that we're really excited
about these findings,
but we also understand
they're still early.
We want to see many more
large-scale field trials
and many more locations
with many more years of data.
However, beyond just these carbon
and climate outcomes,
I think the most exciting thing here
is that we can actually do this
with wild and native and biodiverse
combinations of microorganisms.
And while we pointed
this approach at forestry,
in principle, this kind of science
has the potential to generalize
to all of our managed landscapes.
We can begin asking questions like,
"What does a healthy
agricultural microbiome look like?"
Thinking across both food
and forest agriculture.
And there's reason
to think a biodiversity-first approach
may be particularly powerful here.
And that’s because the
history of agriculture
has been an exercise in reductionism.
We've identified
high-performing plant species,
and then strains,
and then we’ve selectively bred them,
and now we genetically modify them.
And finally, we plant those organisms
out in vast monocultures.
So a single plant species
as far as you can see.
And to be clear,
this has produced
very productive agroecosystems.
But it's also produced ecosystems
we’re coming to understand
are remarkably fragile.
Systems increasingly sensitive
to extreme climate events,
novel pathogens.
Systems incredibly reliant
on chemical inputs,
we're coming to understand
have really serious externalities.
So we now have the data,
computational tools
and the ecological theory
to start going the other way,
to lean into biodiversity and complexity.
And once we do,
the question really becomes,
by rewilding our soils,
can we make our managed
food and forest landscapes
reservoirs of belowground biodiversity?
And in the process,
can we enhance yields and carbon capture
and all the other services
we ask of these ecosystems?
I think there's a lot of reason
to be incredibly hopeful here.
And I think we also
shouldn't be so surprised
that these microscopic organisms
have the potential
for such enormous,
ecosystem-scale effects.
And that’s because we’ve known
now, really for a long time,
that forests are fungi.
And they’re incredibly biodiverse
communities of bacteria and archaea
and protists and microscopic soil
animals and viruses.
Soil is the literal foundation
of terrestrial ecosystems,
and the microbial life that inhabits soil
represents some of the most
complex and biodiverse
communities of life on Earth.
For the first time,
DNA sequencing is turning
the lights on belowground.
It’s allowing us to see these organisms
in unprecedented detail
and at unprecedented scales.
Imagine studying plant biology,
but you never really knew
if you're looking at a sequoia tree
or a sphagnum moss.
And then, all of a sudden, you did.
That's what's happening right now
in global environmental microbiology.
And so we should expect this revolution
in our understanding
of these microscopic organisms,
and particularly fungi,
to transform how we understand
and how we manage our ecosystems
in a foundational way.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)